have you ever dated a cooworker I have
you have I have if I was to say to you
someone had sex in the office I think
it's awesome okay yeah it's fun where oh
it is fun I would assume where do you
think the best place in an office would
be to have said sex said fun sex
definitely the mother's room 100% where
they breastfeed you have a crazy sex
story you'd share with me I was having
sex once and uh I had a standing mirror
that fell on the girl I was having sex
with are you friends with your
co-workers I would say so some of them
yeah yeah some mhm any fantasies that
you've got currently just having sex in
the mother's room I think wants to do
that okay Chris have you had sex in an
office I haven't had sex in an office
you can't look at me like
that I haven't okay okay I believe you
great